[SPEAKER_00]: In the early morning of the seventh and well sun, Merrick comes to relieve Gouge from the watch.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, I want to make sure we both have the same objective and we're clear on what we believe is happening right now.
[SPEAKER_02]: We know Ty is along with us as the meat shield.
[SPEAKER_02]: And his main concern is bringing supplies back to try to relieve some of the stress on Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_02]: Which, maybe you give a shit, it's not really what we're doing here.
[SPEAKER_02]: We were sent to figure out what Owen knew.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think we figured out.
[SPEAKER_02]: Folsom figured out way more than we could.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: To the point that
[SPEAKER_02]: Owen figured out he talked too much.
[SPEAKER_02]: I was a mark by him because he already knows me.
[SPEAKER_02]: You, obviously, as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: So he had to take us out to protect himself at this point.
[SPEAKER_02]: What we're doing here, the guards just being the guard of what they're doing and whether they wanted Owen or wanted to figure out what happened,
[SPEAKER_01]: They don't give a shit about us.
[SPEAKER_02]: We are nothing to them in all this.
[SPEAKER_02]: They have no idea that we're looking deeper into stuff.
[SPEAKER_02]: And we found out what we needed to find out.
[SPEAKER_02]: And I think what we need to do is find our way back and get to Jameis.
[SPEAKER_01]: I agree.
[SPEAKER_01]: Tell Jameis and we need to bring a Monmurg and Cleet back.
[SPEAKER_01]: We need to get rid of this blockade.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, which is the sea turtle and some type of amulet or something that is sea turtle, sea dragon.
[SPEAKER_01]: The artifact.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes, the artifact is basically what's stopping everything, making it possible.
[SPEAKER_01]: And when we saw him leaving, there is a chance that the turtle dragons did follow.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I know the waters well enough where I can see if the Turtle Dragons are there or not.
[SPEAKER_01]: So if we, on our way back, if we find a way out of here, I can see if that blockade, where all those mysterious storms were taking out our ships and stuff, where the trade was cut off, I can go see if those things are still active.
[SPEAKER_01]: If not, we can bring Monmurg in, take out these ships, and kind of free this up a little bit.
[SPEAKER_01]: Jameis would totally be on board.
[SPEAKER_01]: And then, next agenda is, you know,
[SPEAKER_01]: What the hell is Toli doing?
[SPEAKER_01]: We'll figure that out.
[SPEAKER_02]: So, they're starving out Monmurg and they're succeeding.
[SPEAKER_01]: And we need to get to the point.
[SPEAKER_01]: Let's open this trade back up.
[SPEAKER_01]: Let's bring Monmurg Navy here.
[SPEAKER_02]: Do you think they would leave chancing that the Monmurgian Navy would come back again and blow this up?
[SPEAKER_02]: Do you think they've done enough damage and they're sidetracking all this?
[SPEAKER_02]: For the focus here and they've got another something bigger that they're doing.
[SPEAKER_02]: That they would leave and leave with that and need that somewhere else.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't think King Toli knew we were on our way over here.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think this is a set up to, we're gonna set up a blockade, we're gonna starve Monmurg out.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm gonna have the Turled Dragons do their thing.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm gonna go do something else.
[SPEAKER_01]: But take it with?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I think
[SPEAKER_01]: What was he talking about?
[SPEAKER_01]: It was a lich or something?
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, the necromancer?
[SPEAKER_01]: Was that because he made the artifact a long time ago?
[SPEAKER_00]: The lich made the artifact a long time ago.
[SPEAKER_00]: A necromancer made a deal with King Toli to give him the artifact for something else, basically breaking a magical ward on the coast of Selenmor.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So I think our next objective is...
[SPEAKER_01]: So we can get back, get the navy back, resupply.
[SPEAKER_01]: Tell Jameis everything and tell them what's at play.
[SPEAKER_01]: We could even send, have Monmurg go, free up Redshore.
[SPEAKER_01]: We don't necessarily even need to be there for that.
[SPEAKER_02]: No.
[SPEAKER_01]: We take a fleet and we go and try to figure out, I don't know if we want to go to Kane Tolley's Island and see what's there.
[SPEAKER_01]: Or if we want to go after him and see what the hell's going on.
[SPEAKER_02]: Do you know where... Do you know where Jude and Paul went?
[SPEAKER_02]: I cannot remember.
[SPEAKER_02]: Me neither.
[SPEAKER_00]: They were in Monmurg last you saw.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: We left them there.
[SPEAKER_00]: They went to the palace after you guys back from the home.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Alright.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, Jameis will let us know if...
[SPEAKER_02]: We need their assistance or he might have had them on their own errands.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think letting him know is going to really draw what the next plan is and I need to know how much he knows about this artifact or tell him about it if he doesn't know anything about it.
[SPEAKER_01]: We need to bring Folsom in too to let him spill his guts to James about everything.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: I can get us off this island.
[SPEAKER_01]: I did it before.
[SPEAKER_01]: What did I do?
[SPEAKER_01]: A bloated dead shark I tried to sail off on or something?
[SPEAKER_00]: You guys built a little raft.
[SPEAKER_00]: That was from Helm Island back to Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_02]: This is a good 60 miles on the open sea.
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't know if we can steal a ship to get past the blockade unless we can do it at night with no lights.
[SPEAKER_02]: You sail, I sail.
[SPEAKER_02]: They
[SPEAKER_00]: I think Thai sails.
[SPEAKER_00]: They're both Marines.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: They're not, but it's gonna take, you know, with a slew, it'll take two people to be on duty all the time.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: We could, could either of, well, I take it these, the warships are not letting boats out of here.
[SPEAKER_02]: Right.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's why I said at night on something small with no lights.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: If there's anything small enough to do that with, I don't know.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, if there's goods coming in, like all these traders are here, they're not just like sitting here with endless supply that's just spawning in.
[SPEAKER_01]: I assume there's something coming in to keep these traders, keep this, keep Red Shore.
[SPEAKER_02]: Everything's being diverted into here.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: And it's a shit show.
[SPEAKER_02]: There's stuff that can't even be unloaded that's out there.
[SPEAKER_00]: There's trading going on, but most of the merchants are just full cargoes, just sitting there, rotting.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: We're just fucking them over, too, because they're not getting paid.
[SPEAKER_00]: They want to unload their cargo and go home.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: And in a market.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes, not dumping it overboard and going home, unless they feel threatened that they're going to be killed.
[SPEAKER_02]: But I don't think that's happening.
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't even know if there's enough to do that with the Keelander ships.
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't know if they're getting paid to do this.
[SPEAKER_02]: Maybe they're getting paid to make this hold or whatever.
[SPEAKER_02]: But we need to get out of here.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yep, I agree.
[SPEAKER_01]: So I think we should have not stayed in the rocks.
[SPEAKER_01]: We should have taken that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, I don't know if we could have gotten past it, but we've got to figure out how to get out of here.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I agree.
[SPEAKER_02]: And if there's anything on the rocky side of the island, any type of industry, fishing, something that we can go down and slip away that way versus going back into the middle of it,
[SPEAKER_02]: You're going to have to use your ice for that.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yep, I agree.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right.